en el vídeo anterior encontramos la
respuesta al escalón de un circuito rc y
ahora resolveremos un ejemplo real aquí
tenemos la respuesta total de nuestro
circuito a una entrada escalón vamos a
hacer más espacio para poder resolver
nuestro ejemplo volvemos a dibujar el
circuito que alimentamos con un escalón
que va de 0.2 volts hasta 1.1 volts
nuestra r será igual a un kilo y la
capacitancia será de 4 micro farage
pongamos estos valores en nuestra
solución y veamos que obtenemos primero
resolvemos r por c que es igual a un
kilo por 4 micros
y esto es igual a k es más tres y micro
es menos 61 por 4 es 4 y más 3 menos 6
es 10 a la menos 3
estos son segundos por lo que nos queda
4 milisegundos
sustituyamos los demás valores vete es
igual la respuesta total al escalón es
igual a b 0 que es punto 2 menos bs que
es 1.1 por el ala menos t entre 4
milisegundos más
ds y ds es 1.1 gráfica esto con mi
computadora y veamos qué tanto se acerca
a lo que grafica mos antes aquí está
dt o la respuesta total de nuestra red
rc al voltaje escalón el voltaje escalón
aquí se muestra en color rosa y va desde
0.2 world hasta ops me equivoqué
pongamos aquí el número correcto
si ven esta gráfica y la comparan con lo
que grafica mos al principio verán que
son muy parecidas así que el voltaje de
salida el voltaje de nuestro capacitor
bt comienza en b 0 0.2 y termina en bs
que es 1.2 en este caso aquí está la
respuesta forzada y en el intervalo
tenemos esta suave curva exponencial así
luce la respuesta al escalón de un
circuito rc